hey John how's your day going that was a
good pun hey there this is Sam QB I'm an
editor at GQ we're gonna take the next
30 days and see who has the longest
fullest best beard of all I'm pretty
sure I'm ghetto
we're like a gang of babies right now
just the softest gang in town yeah this
is the beer I know I'm in trouble
we're gonna go on record and say Chris's
no shot we've seen the best you got I
don't know if you and it's not another
month it's not enough you know what
those could be beards why it stinks
that's what it feels like it feels like
steak dinner on the losers but then I
have to eat dinner
I would say my sort of beard action is
medieval conquer the lame dad the hot
seat hipster I'm Jewish so like I can
say that right I'm feeling pretty good I
I feel like this is this is a beard that
you can actually call a beard which
which I'm happy about
there's no rhyme or reason to what's
going on here and my girlfriend is ready
to murder me at this point
there's no way I'm going to feel pretty
good about my performance it's been a
while since I've grown a beard from
scratch but I've got the darkness so
couldn't fool you into thinking I'm
winning we all look I don't know it
ranges from terrible to okay I think no
names I'll take that okay so okay so if
we think outside the lines
yep and our definition of what a beard
have you I'm back Christmas game over
cannot see that I kind of feel like I
got my my power back none of us can get
the red it's like sounds oh there a
scientific term for that does it mean
something I think it means you die
earlier right probably I might also be a
Viking that's like super unlikely I
think I don't I think I kind of feel
like everyone won Chris gets sort of
best alternative beard Matt gets best
thanked out it's back here and I get
ready speared maybe I know Viking dude
that's Viking so we're all winners and
we're all gonna donate to the No Shave
November
we did it guys our wallets medalist
thank you guys for watching go ahead and
subscribe to gqueues youtube channel and
we've a comment down below and let us
know who won